GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVER
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF- WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN IN
HERE TO A SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING THIS
A CENTRAL COMMITTEE HEARING-
HERE IN THE CAPITAL IN OUR
NORMAL ROOM THIS MORNING WE'VE
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
OUR PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND I AM
FOR USE. TO ALLOW THE ACCESS WE
MUST HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC- WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
ALSO BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I'M GOING TO ANNOUNCE IT
RIGHT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBERS.
844-291-6364 SO THAT'S.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. THIRTY TO FORTY FORTY
NINE ONE SO. THREE TO FOUR ZERO
FOUR NINE. ONE WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY INDIVIDUALS ONE AT A
TIME TODAY WILL OPEN YOUR LINE
AND AT THAT TIME HE WILL
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME THE BILL NUMBER
TWO WHICH YOU ARE REFERRING AND
IT IS IN YOUR POSITION
OBVIOUSLY IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN PATIENT. I'LL
MAKE MAINTAIN DECORUM AND-
DURING THE HEARING IS CUSTOMARY
AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE- OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTION- MUTED
IT'S ALSO A GOOD TIME TO REMIND
EVERYBODY PROVIDING TERM
TESTIMONY THAT THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE SO PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL ASPECTS
OF THE BILL YOU ARE TESTIFYING
ON AND PLEASE REFRAIN FROM PER
ROOM HEATING PRIOR TEST ONLY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO RE LITIGATE
THE MERITS THE PROPOSALS BEFORE
US TODAY PASSED. THE SCHOOL
IMPACTS WELL YOU HAVE HAS BEEN
MADE IN HERE PROCESS AND
CONDUCTOR HERE IN A CLOSE TO
THE SAME MAN AS KIND THERE MAY
BE SOME LAG TIME FOR GEORGIA TO
THE OF NEW ON TOOL AND
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT AS WE
ALL ARE IN THIS. TOGETHER SHOW
WE HAVE A FULL HEARING TO. I'D
LIKE TO THANK EVERY FOR BEING
HERE- WE ARE HEARING TO
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE CAN
CONSTITUTIONAL MEMBERS TODAY.
BOTH OF WHICH WILL BE ELIGIBLE
FOR DO PASSED MOTION SINCE THEY
MUST BE APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THIS WEEK IN ORDER
TO APPEAR. ON THE NOVEMBER
BALLOT SO LET'S ESTABLISH OUR
CORPSMAN CALL THIS MEETING
OFFICIALLY TO ORDER. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL- SENATORS
PORTANTINO I'M HERE PORTANTINO
HERE BATES. BATES HERE BRADFORD.
EFFORT HERE HELLO. HILL HERE
JONES YEAH JONES HERE LEYVA
LEYVA HERE AND WHY CASKEY. HERE
I CASKEY HERE IF SEVEN MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE AND A
QUORUM DUE TO A STRANGE
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF THE
HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS A NEW PROTOCOLS-
WILL HAVE A TIME LIMIT ON OUR
TESTIMONY SO THEY'LL BE THREE
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY ON EACH
SIDE OF EACH MEASURE. AND THEN
THERE WILL BE- THOSE FROM THE
PUBLIC WISHING O SPEAK I WILL
BE ABLE TO ADD THEIR POSITION
ONLY AFTER THAT. SO WE HAVE-
ACA FOR. BY MISTER MULLIN AND I
SEE MR LOW IN THE AUDIENCE AS
WELL WHO CARES DEEPLY ABOUT THE
SAME ISSUE AS WELL. AND SO
GENTLEMAN IF YOU COULD COME UP
AND TELL US ABOUT A CA FOR-
IT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT TO US
AND I KNOW IT IS IMPORTANT TO
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
CONVENIENCE. AT THE EARLY OUR-
I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SENATORS APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A C. FOR
THIS MORNING EASY FOR WOULD
CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
FIRST TIME VOTERS AND BOOST THE
YOUTH VOTER TURNOUT BY ALLOWING
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS TO VOTE IN
THE PRIMARY ELECTION. PROVIDED
IN THIS IS IMPORTANT THAT THEY
WILL BE EIGHTEEN BY THE GENERAL
ELECTION EIGHTY FOUR WOULD LAY
THE FOUNDATION TO BUILD THE
VOTING HAVE IT AT AN EARLY AGE
ALLOWING SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS TO
PARTICIPATE IN PRIMARY
ELECTIONS WOULD COMPLEMENT THE
CIVIC EDUCATION MANY RECEIVING
HIGH SCHOOL INCREASING THE
LIKELIHOOD. THAT THE STUDENTS
TO BECOME LIFELONG VOTERS THIS
IDEA IS NOT A NEW ONE NEARLY
HALF OF THE STATES IN THE US
BOTH RED AND BLUE STATES
ALREADY ALLOW SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLD TO PARTICIPATE IN PRIMARIES
AND CAUCUSES FIRST TIME VOTER
SHOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
PART TO PARTICIPATE IN A FULL
ELECTION CYCLE PRIMARY. IN
GENERAL WE HAVE- I BELIEVE
DOCTOR MINDY ROMERO WITH US- TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS BEFORE I DO
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO- BRING UP
MY- JOINT AUTHOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW I THANK HIM FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN PARTNERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE WELCOME HIM TO MAKE.
SOME COMMENTS. BUT I'M THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
INCOME. AS YOU KNOW THERE NOW
NUMBER OF THIS. IN THE ASSEMBLY
BUT AFRICAN NUYS IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF- SUPPORTIVE
SUPPORTING ONE MEASURE- WITH
RESPECT TO OF THE SENATE. OF
USE HAVE THIS MEASURE BEFORE
YOU. AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
THIS ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND HAVE ALREADY IS IN
EXISTENCE IN SEVENTEEN OTHER
STATES INCLUDING. THE MEXICO
NORTH CAROLINA OHIO SOUTH
CAROLINA UTAH VIRGINIA VERMONT
WEST VIRGINIA AND A NUMBER OF
OTHER STATES SEVENTEEN OHER
STATES SO THIS IS NOT ANY
MEASURE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE IN ENCOURAGING
THAT WE RESTORE ACTIVE
PARTICIPATION IN OUR CITIZENRY.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
SO IS- MISS MEN THE DOCTOR
ROMERO GOING TO BE OFFERING
TESTIMONY OR JUST HERE FOR
QUESTIONS. I BELIEVE WE'RE
ADVISED SAID SHE SHOULD JUST BE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTION
SHOULD THERE BE STE IF SHE
WANTS TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS
SHE'S WELCOME I THINK SHE'S ON
AND I'LL TALK TO REMEMBER WAS
ON THE LINE. BUT YOU DON'T. I
DON'T KNOW IF I GET ON THE LINE
HE IS SHE'S ONLINE DOT. AMERICA
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ADD A CUP.
COMMON YOU MAY. I CERTAINLY ARE
HOW MUCH TIME DO I HAVE. THREE
MINUTES. A THREE MINUTE OKAY I
LOW ON WILL I WILL TALK LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE MERITS OF THE
BILL THAT ALL RIGHT I'M.
WORKING ON A VERY QUICKLY IS ON
THEM. ACT CALENDAR RESEARCH
ACOSTA CAL YOU ENGAGEMENT.
CRISTINA HEADQUARTERS
SACRAMENTO. I AND WE DON'T TAKE
THE ON THE OAKLAND ATTACK ABOUT
THAT. BUT THE FIELD AROUND
EVERY. GUILT I THINK YOU'RE
LOOKING ABOUT. SO TO START A
POLITICAL PARTY TO OF COURSE AS
WE ALL KNOW HERE IS. OWNERSHIP
BUT IN CALIFORNIA IN UNITED
STATES. FOUR PERCENT- IN
CALIFORNIA BUT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AGED EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR IT
WAS. SIXTEEN PERCENT. AND WE'RE
FOR EVERYBODY THAT TURNOUT
ACTUALLY INCREASED OVER THE
MOST RECENT COLLECTION WHICH IS
OF COURSE THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
PRIMARY WE ALL KNOW THAT-
INCREASED ABOUT FOUR PERCENTAGE
POINTS. YOU CURRENT ACTUALLY
DECREASED ABOUT A PERCENT. OVER
ABOUT TWENTY SIXTEEN PRIMARY-
IF WE LOOK AT AGE EIGHTY AT AGE
SIXTY FIVE CLASS. I'M THEIR
TURNOUT WAS 56% ARE ELIGIBLE
TURNOUT IN THAT TWENTY TWENTY
PRIMARY THE YOUNG PEOPLE AGED
YOU TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN
PERCENT. AGE SIXTY FIVE CLASS
56% SO AGAIN FORTY PERCENTAGE
POINT. DIFFERENCE SO BUT I
ALWAYS HAVE TO SIDE OF COURSE
TO GET THESE NUMBERS CAN BE
DAUNTING THEY CAN FEEL. THEY
ARE CERTAINLY ENTRENCHED IN OUR
SOCIETY THIRTY THREE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN TERMS OF
PARTICIPATION. BUT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO BE PERMANENT. BY ANY
MEANS- THERE ARE THINGS. REAL
REAL. I SHOULD SAY THEIR REAL
REASON WHY WE SEE THESE
DISPARITY AND OR ACTION THAT WE
CAN TAKE IN A QUICKLY JUST
BECAUSE YOU'RE HAS BEEN.
FOCUSED ON YOUTH. OF THE LAST
NUMBER OF OUR CYCLE THERE
DEFINITELY RUSH. BUT THE STILL
MUCH MORE WORK TO BE SO
BARRIERS. THE LACK OF REACH AND
MOBILIZATION A PEOPLE CATCH
FROM CAN BE IN CAN BECAUSE SEEN
AS NOT LIKELY GO. I DON'T GET
IT EDUCATION OF THAT RIGHT THAT
LEVEL BECAUSE THIS CYCLE AND-
THE LACK OF INTER. AND IN HERE.
OR A BY. I SAY I. HABITS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NEW TO THE
PROCESS IN THERE SO THAT DOES
REALLY SERVE THEIR NAY. GET
THAT INFORMATION. WHILE AND
ALLOW OF COURSE. ABOUT
EDUCATION AND ALWAYS WONDER TO
GOOD OLD. BUT WE GOT REALLY
HAVE COMMITMENT. A LARGE DEGREE.
AROUND OUR YOUNG PEOPLE BUT RE
SHOWS. THEY ALL ARE VERY MUCH
SURE MANY OF PEOPLE FIND
CONNECT. TO WHY VOTING NOW SO
THE CARE VERY DEEPLY THEIR CAN
BE AND ACCESS THE YOU MOBILIZED
THEY CAN BE APPLIED THERE ARE
WE KNOW THAT IT CONNECT THEY
MAKE CAN. TO THE- WHAT THEY
CARE ABOUT TO THE- BUILDING AND
THAT PROCESS. THEN THAT CAN GET
THEM THE REASON RIGHT THEN THE
MOTOR TO PARTICIPATE IN. OUR
ELECT. THAT CONNECTION TO BE
MADE. AND THINGS LIKE RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN US LIKE MY DEBATE AND
MARK. TO INCREASE SO LIKELY TO
THE PERSON TO ACT REGISTER. AS
WELL AS- ACTUALLY BUILDING AND
SOMETHING LIKE A. EIGHT YOU
KNOW IT. A BIG. YOU WILL YOU
THINK ABOUT MAKING A CONNECTION
MAKING. THE POLITICAL REAL. TO
BE ABLE TO TALK TO YOUNG PEOPLE
PERSON AND BE ABLE CONNECT TO
THE JOHN IF YOU GO IN THIS CAR.
FOR TO THE TO THE PRIMARY. YOU
LITERALLY ARE HAS SHAPE THE
THAT THE LOW OF THE BY IN THE
UP OF THE IN THE GENERAL. THAT
CAN BE AND ARE YOU TO FOR SO
THAT YOU LIKE YOUNG FOR ON A-
AT THE DEPENDING ON THE TIME OF
YEAR RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO TALK A
REAL. ACTUALLY SO. HER ESTATE
THE RESEARCH INTERESTED SUCH. A
MATCH. CAN BE. A POSITIVE AND.
HOW THE POOL FOR MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE THANK YOU WHAT COMES TO
LAUGHED INCREASING THEIR
NUMBERS I WILL LEAVE IT THERE
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE SEE THERE'S NO IN
THIS THAT WAY TO TEST IN. AND
DO WE HAVE TO FORTY UP YES WE
DO. SIR ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEN NINE I THINK WE HAVE
A COUPLE PEOPLE ONLINE WE WILL
GO TO OUR PHONES THOSE FOLKS
ONLINE PLEASE CONFINE YOUR-
POSITIVE TESTIMONY TO YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION THIS IS THE TIME FOR
THOSE WHO SUPPORT. THE EIGHTY
FOUR TO WAIT IN. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF A CA FOR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT THEY SEE A FOR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
JUST A BRIEF
MOMENT LONGER. IN OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM MINE FIFTEEN.
NINE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. MORNING YOUR
ROSA THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ACA FOR THANK YOU. AND ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF A CA FOR PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME ON YOUR PHONE.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
INTO. ALL RIGHT AT THIS TIME WE
WILL MOVE TO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION OF A CA FOR I SEE NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM. I SEE NO ONE
IN THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY OUR
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
LINE WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION DAY CA FOR.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF ACA FOR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF ACA FOR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT AT THIS POINT
WE WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION OF THE HEARING
I WILL NOT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS MEASURE. TO ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR THE OFFICE. OF MISTER WHITE
CASKET. ARM ON THE FISCAL
IMPACT BECAUSE WE ARE THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE I
UNDERSTAND THAT EACH PAGE OF
THE BALLOT INITIATIVES COULD
COST EIGHTY THOUSAND. EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY TO SPEED SAID. WHAT I'M
CONCERNED WHICH IS THE
SECRETARY STATES ESTIMATE THAT
IT'S GONNA BE AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY FROM GENERAL
FUNDS ANSWER READ THE STAFF
REPORT. THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
NEW REPLENISHED EXISTING
REGISTRATION CARDS. AND I'M
WONDERING WHY. BECAUSE I'M I'M
SAYING WE HAVE. IF WE MAKING
NEW. CARDS I GET THAT AND YOU
CAN PUT IN WILL YOU BE EIGHTEEN
BY ELECTION DAY AND ALL THAT.
BUT THE EXISTING REGISTRATION
CARDS IF WE HONOR THEM THERE'S
NO REASON TO DUMP. AND SPEND A
QUARTER MILLION BUCKS A NEW
CARDS. WONDER IF YOU COULD
EXPLAIN WHY. THAT IS A
NECESSARY COST IN THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. THIS
STAYS OFF IS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE I THINK THAT WAS- OUT
OF AN ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION IF
THERE WERE. ANY ADDITIONAL
COSTS BUT MY SENSE OF THIS IS.
THAT THIS COULD BE BUILT INTO
THE EXISTING PROCESS SEES. IN
THERE WOULD BE MINIMAL COST
FRANKLY IF ANY. BECAUSE THE
REGISTRATION PROCESS WE'RE NOT
ADDING AN ADDITIONAL LAYER FOR
EXAMPLE TO THESE THESE COSTS.
THE EXISTING FORMS- WOULD BE
APPLICABLE WE ALREADY HAVE A
PRE REGISTRATION PROCESS FOR
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLDS- THE MECHANISMS ARE IN
PLACE TO DO THIS. EASILY AND WE
DO HAVE THE BENEFIT OF HAVING
OVER OVER TWENTY ACTUALLY
NEARLY HALF OF THE STATE'S
HAVING DONE THIS ALREADY IT'S
IT PASSES CONSTITUTIONAL
MUSTER. UP CALIFORNIA JUST LATE
TO THE GAME ON THIS ONE- AND
IT'S A NATURAL EXTENSION OF THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE ON PRE
REGISTRATION AND THE COST
FRANKLY IS. A NON ISSUE. AND
JUST IT'S IN OUR STAFF REPORT
IN ITS STATE PUTS IN THERE THIS
IS GOING WITH THE BALLOT IN
THIS NOVEMBER SO THIS IS. GOING
TO TELL. CAN TWENTY YOU WOULD
THINK THAT THE SECTOR. A BUNCH.
OUT THREE CAR. BACK THEN TO
SPRING THIS FOR JUST YOU OF
THAT WE HAVE A IN THE ONLINE IS
GOING TO BE NOTHING I MEAN THE
TO CHANGE THE THAT INFORMATION
SO I JUST DRAW THAT FISCAL
ELEMENT OF THIS TO MAY. NOT
THANK. SENATE TO BRADFORD
QUESTION AS WELL I JUST WANT TO
MAKE COM ARE JUST ONE THING
BOTH AUTHORS FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS MEASURE THINK IT'S VITALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT'S WELL OVERDUE I JUST TAKE
EXCEPTION TO ONE THING THAT-
SOME OF THE MOST SAYS HE SAYS
HIS WILL REINVIGORATE I THINK
IT ESTABLISHES SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T EXIST HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OR THIS NATION SO I
THINK IT WILL BE. THE START OF.
VOTER PARTICIPATION AS WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN. A MEASURE
CHAIR THIS IS THE SIX THE TENTH
AT THIS THE FIRST TIME IT'S
BEEN HEARD IN THE SENATE THE
IDEA ORIGINATED WITH MY FATHER
WAS A THIRTY THREE YEAR
GOVERNMENT TEACHER SIXTY FOR
ITSELF SENTENCES FOR HIGH
SCHOOL IT WAS FINALLY GETTING
AND STAY IN THE SENATE I'M
GRATEFUL I'M HOPE WITH THAT WE
GET OF THE SENATE FLOOR TODAY
TO FOR ME ONCE AND FOR ALL GET
THIS TO THE VOTERS.
CALIFORNIA'S LET ME LAY. HELLO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY THAT
YOU'RE GOOD ALL RIGHT MOVE THE
BILLS. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER HILL I WILL TELL YOU
MISTER MULLIN THAT'S MR UMBERG
AND I WERE FINALLY DISCUSSING
YOUR FATHER LAST NIGHT. AS WELL
SINCE WE BOTH.SERVED WITH HIM.
IN THE ASSEMBLY SO. PLEASE
SHARE OUR COMMENTS WITH YOUR
FAMILY. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL IT IS THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO DO PASSED
THE SENATE FOR. ACA FOR THE
MOTION IS THAT THE MEASURE BE
ADOPTED AND REFER TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO I. PORTANTINO
HI BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HI BILL I JONES OWNS NO
LEYVA AYE LEYVA BY MY COUNT SKI
CASKEY ARE. WE HAVE FIVE TO ONE
THAT A RESOLUTION OR SHOULD
MEET FASTER SHERMAN IS OUT FIVE
TO ONE AND WE'LL GO TO THE
SENATE FLOOR THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO A
CA ELEVEN ALSO AUTHORED BY MR
MULLIN AND- PLEASE TELL US
ABOUT A CA ELEVENTH. MORNING
EMS SHARE MEMBERS PRESENTING A
CA ELEVEN AS A COMPROMISE
MEASURE TO REPLACE THE MEASURE
WHICH HAS QUALIFIED FOR THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT ENSURING THAT
FUNDING FOR FIRE PROTECTION AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT REVENUES ARE
PROTECTED. ALLOWING FOR
FLEXIBILITY AND REFORM IN
CALIFORNIA'S PROPERTY TAX
FORMULAS WHILE LEAVING THE
PROTECTIONS OF PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN INTACT THIS MEASURE
CONTAINS SEVERAL PROVISIONS
INTENDED TO INCREASE THE
INCREASE THE STOCK OF AVAILABLE
HOUSING AND PROVIDE PROTECTIONS
TO VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS IN
THE HOUSING MARKET WELL
CREATING PROTECTED FUNDING FOR
UNDER FUNDED FIRE DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. ENSURING
THAT COUNTIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RECEIVE EQUALAND
EQUITABLE FUNDING THROUGH THE
PROVISIONS ECA ELEVEN WILL
PROTECT THE FAMILY TRANSFERS
WHEN A FAMILY MEMBER IS GOING
TO TREAT THE NEW PROPER NEW
PROPERTY AS THEIR PRIMARY
RESIDENCE. HE WOULD CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLE FOR VACATION OR OTHER
YOU TO NOT LOSE PRIMARY
RESIDENCE. BY CLOSING THESE
LOOPHOLES THE STATE WILL BE
ABLE TO GENERATE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR FIRE
PROTECTION EMERGENCY SERVICES
OTHER CRITICAL LOCAL PROGRAMS
TO SUPPORT THE HOMELESS AND
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OR TO HELP FUND THE DEVELOPMENT
OF NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. WITH ME
TODAY- CHRISTY BOMA OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRUSTS PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AS WELL AS- NETTO
OF THE REALTORS ASSOCIATION.
AND THEY ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS WITH REGARD TO THE
FUNDING FORMULAS AND ANY OF THE
TECHNICAL CHANGES THAT WILL BE
MADE SHOULD THE VOTERS APPROVED
A CA ELEVEN THIS FALL. THANK
YOU. MS BROWN. WE HAVE A
QUESTION YOU'RE GONNA MAKE A
COMMENT. MISTER CHAIRMAN OVER
HERE FOR YOUR QUESTIONS
CRISTINA I'M ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. THANK YOU TO
CENTER HILL FOR LEADING ON THIS
ISSUE AND HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT- AND
MISTER OWN OWN NEATO IS HERE AS
WELL JUST FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THESE ONLINE I
BELIEVE. I'M ON THE OTHER LINE
OFFICE OF MISTER CHAIR CURRENT
AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
MEASURE AWESOME WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN THIS ROOM WHO'S HERE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR AS ANYONE IN
TWENTY FORTY. NO ONE THERE IS
OR ANYONE ON THE LINE IN FAVOR
OF THIS ON THE GENERAL LINE.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF A CA ELEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF ACA A LEVIN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONE MOMENT.
TO BE
JUST A BRIEF MOMENT LONGER.
UHHUH AT NINE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH CHRIS WROTE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. TWO HC A ELEVEN
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE ROOM FOR
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY ANYONE
ONLINE IN OPPOSITION TO TWENTY
TWO ACA ELEVEN. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF A CA
ELEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AC EIGHT ELEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE COME. AT
THIS MOMENT WILL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD TO MIKE
MISTER HILL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IN THE YOU KNOW THIS IS
AN EXAMPLE OF GOOD GOVERNMENT
AND GOOD RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
OUR HOUSES BECAUSE THIS IS KIND
OF A HYBRID APPROACH WITH A
NUMBER OF MEASURES THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN A C. ELEVEN THAT
KIND OF BRING TOGETHER. I THINK
THE PERFECT SOLUTION TO WHAT WE
TRY TO DO IN GOVERNMENT WHICH
IS PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES FOR THE FOR
FIREFIGHTERS FOR THE OTHERS
PUBLIC SAFETY AND FIRST
RESPONDERS THAT TO PROVIDE SUCH
GREAT SERVICE TO US SECONDLY
CLOSEST SOME LOOPHOLES THAT WE
FIND IN THE- IN. THE CURRENT
SYSTEM- AN APPROACH THAT
CERTAINLY GOT MY ATTENTION
EARLY ON WHEN PEOPLE REALLY
ABUSE THE SYSTEM AND PROVIDE-
THAT- OR ACTUALLY TAKING MONEY
IN KEEPING THE REVENUE THAT'S
NECESSARY AND IT'S JUST AN-
UNEQUAL AND UNFAIR IN THE WAY
OF HAS BEEN. APPROACHED IT AND
ALSO THE ASPECT OF BEING ABLE
TO RESOLVE A PROBLEM OR AN
INITIATIVE THAT HAS BEEN
PROPOSED WHEN THIS CAN BE.
ALLOW FOR THE CONVERSATION THE
DISCUSSION AND THE COMPROMISE
THIS NECESSARY TO PLAY
SOMETHING ON THE BALLOT THAT
DOES SO MUCH MORE. THAN WAS
ORIGINALLY ATICIPATED SO I
JUST THINK THIS IS A GREAT-
pGREAT WORK AND- WAS SENATOR
HERTZBERG WAS WORKING HARD ON
THIS. AS WELL AS IT IS
YOURSELF- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN AND- THE STAFF FROM OF
FROM BOTH HOUSES TO COME
TOGETHER ON THIS THIS GREAT
COMPROMISE OR JUST. HONORED TO
BE A PART OF IT AND- CERTAINLY
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
IT TODAY. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE RESTORE CAST. AM HE
WOULDN'T BE YOU WON'T YOU KNOW
I GET THE SPIN SAY ON REVENUE
FROM THE ON SECONDHOMES SO YOU
CAN'T TAKE YOUR PROP THIRTEEN
AND GO UP AND GET A CABIN OR WE
WHAT WE USED TO CALL CAP AND
THE CONCERN IS THE SECOND PART.
THAT THE ALLEY **** CALCULATES
THE NET LOSS FROM ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE FIFTY FIVE
YEARS OLD THAT ARE GOING TO BE
TRANSFERRING PROPERTY AND NOT
PAYING THE PROP. THE D.
INCREASE VALUE TO PROPERTY TAX
THAT YOU DO RIGHT NOW- IN I
GUESS THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE
IS THE- XCELERATED IMPACT ON
THE- WILDLIFE URBAN INTERFACE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A LOT OF. A
LOT OF HIGH VALUED HOUSES THAT
ARE IN THE BAY AREA- LOS
ANGELES THE PEOPLE WOULD SELL
AND MOVE UP INTO- AN AREA
THAT'S ALREADY STRESS WITH WITH
DEVELOPMENT- OR AT LEAST SOME
OF US WOULD WOULD SAY SO. THE
BUT THEY'RE TALKING THAT THE
LAW THE IMPACTIS GOING TO BE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON THE
LOCAL- SCHOOLS IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OVER YEARS. HOW DO
YOU BALANCE OFF THOSE. THOSE
THOSE TWO PRESSURES WHEN I SEE
CLOSING THE LOOPHOLE THAT
THAT'S THAT'S EASY TO GET IN
BUT THE PRESSURE ON. WE ALREADY
HAVE PRESSURE BECAUSE OF THE
FIRE FIGHTING IN THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT WE'RE SPENDING TO
TRY TO SUPPRESS FIRE NETWORK
ADDING. AN INCENTIVE FOR PEOPLE
TO GO TO THESE. SHOWS VIEW FULL
AREAS THERE IS A- A NET GAIN OF
UP TO BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
OVER TIME. BEAT THE INCREASE
COMES IN THE VOLUME OF
TRANSACTIONS. I BELIEVE THAT-
COUNTIES WILL BE MADE WHOLE
PROP NINETY A GUARANTEE THAT
CAT SCHOOLS WILL BE
APPROPRIATELY FUNDED THERE
WON'T BE AT A LOSS THERE THE
FORMULA IS A COMPLICATED ONE
BUT IF- THE FOR THE ON THE
PROPERTY TAX PORTABILITY
PROVISION THE SCENE OVER FIFTY
FIVE WHEN THEY MOVED TO A NEW
RESIDENTS IF THAT IS. OF
GREATER VALUE THEY WILL
ACTUALLY BE PAYING A MODEST
ABOUT MORE IN PROPERTY TAXES.
BUT IT'S REALLY THE VOLUME OF
TRANSACTIONS AND FREEING UP
THOSE PROPERTIES THAT ADDRESSES
THE AVAILABLE AVAILABILITY OF
HOUSING STOCK ISSUE BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS THERE IS A
PROJECTED NET GAIN BUT IT IS IT
IS COMPLICATED BECAUSE THERE'S
LOSSES IN SOME COLUMNS. GAINS
IN THE OTHER COLUMN BUT IT NETS
OUT UP TO A BILLION A YEAR IN
THIS FUNDS UNDER FIND
HISTORICALLY UNDERFUNDED FIRE
DISTRICTS SO THAT'S A THAT'S A
VALUABLE PORTION OF THIS BUT IT
ALSO- MAKE SURE THAT COUNTIES
ARE HELD HARMLESS. IN ANY
TRANSACTIONS WITHIN THE COUNTY
FOR EXAMPLE THERE WILL BE NO-
I'D NET LOSS CELL I'M CONFIDENT
THAT THIS WILL. GENERATE UP TO
BILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE BUT-
WHAT DREW ME TO THIS WAS THAT
TAX FAIRNESS HE'S VERY HONESTLY
OF THIS WITH THE SECOND THIRD
FOURTH HOMES THAT ARE USED AS-
VACATION PROPERTIES. THEIR USE
HAS RENTAL PROPERTIES SO
ESSENTIALLY YOU CAN INHERIT THE
SECOND THIRD AND FOURTH HOMES
BUT YOU CAN IT HURT THE TAX
RATE. SO THAT IS WHAT DREW ME
TO THIS MEASURE. AND THE
FORMULA CAN GET TECHNICAL AND
CAN GET COMPLICATED IF KERR HAS
ANYTHING TO ADD SPECIFIC TO THE
QUESTION AROUND. THE PROPERTY
TAX PORTABILITY AND HOW WE CAN
ENSURE THAT WE ACTUALLY
GENERATING. NEW REVENUES I I'D
WALK A MILE IN HIS CALM AS WELL.
IF. TWO ANOS WORKS WHERE ALL
THE ACT. HI YEAH BUT A SIMILAR
I CAN SPEAK TO THAT QUICKLY
COLONEL- YES WORKS WERE ON
BEHALF OF THE REALTORS
ASSOCIATION. ORDER THE
EQUALIZATION DOES TRACKING DATA
ON THE NUMBER OF THESE-
PROPERTY TAX BASE TRANSIT OCCUR
NOW OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
IT'S AVERAGE FOUR THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED TWELVE PER YEAR.
OBVIOUSLY THAT NUMBER WILL GROW
UNDER THIS MEASURE WE DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH IS IT. OR OR
TRIPLE- IT IT'S HARD TO TELL-
BUT EVEN EVEN IF THE DOUBLING
OR TRIPLING WHICH WE COULD SEE
NEXT ORDINARY. THE STAFF
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THAT THE
AVERAGE WILL PROPERTY TAX LOSS
ON THE REPLACEMENT HOME IS
FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY
DOLLARS PER YEAR PER HOME. SO
WHAT THE CURRENT RATE OF FORTY
SIX HUNDRED TRANSFERS PER YEAR
AT FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLAR LOT
THAT'S A LITTLE OVER SEVEN
DOLLARS SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR STATEWIDE. IN PROPERTY
TAX LOSSES. THE NUMBER THE
NUMBER OF CANCER DOUBLES OR
TRIPLES ARE LOOKING AT FIFTEEN
TO TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
STATEWIDE IN REVENUE REDUCTION
ALL THAT COMPONENT BASED ON THE
NUMBERS. IN THE STAFF ANALYSIS
IN BASED ON THE HISTORICAL DATA
COLUMBIA WE ON THE NUMBER OF
TRANSFERS OF THE PROPERTY BASE.
I THINK IT'S ALL IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT THAT. WELL THERE WILL
BE LESS PROPERTY TAX PAID ON
THE REPLACEMENT HOLDEN THERE
MIGHT OTHERWISE BE. SOLD TO
SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T TRANSFER
THE PROPERTY TAX BASE. THE
ORIGINAL HOME OF THE OF THE
INDIVIDUAL BY IN THE
REPLACEMENT. HAVE TO BE SOLD
UNDER THE RULES YOU CAN'T. WHAT
WE CALL YOUR YOUR PROPERTY TAX
BASE TO A NEW HOME UNLESS YOU
SELL YOUR ORIGINAL OUT. AND
WHEN THE ORIGINAL HOME IS SOLD
IT'S GOING TO BE SOLD FOR. MORE
THAN THEM IN THE BASE YOUR
VALUES CAN BE SOBER FOR MARKET
VALUE WHICH IS ALMOST ALWAYS
MORE SOTHERE'S GOING TO BE. A
PROPERTY TAX INCREASE ON THE
ORIGINAL- SO THESE NUMBERS
BEGIN OFFSET EACH OTHER THEY'LL
BE. COURSE THE LESSER TAX PAID
THAT MIGHT. OTHERWISE BE ON THE
REPLACEMENT BUT THEY'LL BE MORE
TAX PAID ON THE ORIGINAL HOME
WHEN THE WHEN THE OLDER SELLS
IT TO BOOT. SHOULDERS ACOSTA
DOWN THERE I THINK YOU KNOW FOR.
BASED ON THE NUMBERS AND STAFF
REPORT FOR EVERY FIFTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS LOSS ON A
REPLACEMENT ON THE PROPERTY TAX
WILL BE FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
EUGENE. WHEN THIS WHEN THE
ORIGINAL MISSILE. AND I THINK
IT'S A REMEMBER MULLIN POINTED
OUT THAT YOU DEPENDING ON WHERE
THE HOMEOWNER CELLS ARE HOME
AND- IN WHAT COUNTY THAT THAT
IS LOCATED. AND WHAT COUNTY
THEY MOVED TO THE TRANSMITTER
PROPERTY. TAX BASE. NO THAT HAD
BEEN SOME CONCERN OUR DATA THE
OTHER REAL. SOLUTION TO KATE
THERE WILL NEVER BE A NET.
COUNTY TO LACKEY NOT LAWSUIT.
BUT THE COMPROMISE HERE AND IN
THE PROTECT YOUR AGE ELEVEN. IT
CAN AMERICAN THAT THAT. THE
REPORT THERE EVERY IN THE
COUNTY THE EXPERIENCE OF THEIR
REVENUE LAW. IT WILL BE WHOLE
TO THE- IN THE COUNTY REVERIE
PROTECT UNDER IS INCLUDE IN
THIS. OCELOT BUT THAT IS HOW
THE WE THINK THAT THE REGULAR
SET OF COURT OF WELL NOW BE
SIGNIFICANT AND WILL LIKELY
OFFICE. BY A STATEWIDE. BECAUSE
OF THE OVER HOMES RICH BOX SO
AND REASSESS. ALL RIGHT ANY
OTHER MR HELL COMMITTEE CHAIR
THE IN ALL. A YOU LOOK AT THE I
THINK THE PORT. OF THE PROPERTY
TAXES KIND OF THAT THAT TRAIN
LEFT THE STATION. THAT
INITIATIVE THAT WILLBE ON THE
BALLOT IS THAT A POPULAR ISSUE
AND IT WOULD PROBABLY. PASSED
IN NOVEMBER AND- IN THAT WOULD
BE- WE HAVE THAT AS WELL BUT
WE'RE GETTING A LOT OF BETTER
THINGS I BELIEVE IS THAT PART
OF THIS PACKAGE THAT COME
TOGETHER THE SECOND THING IS.
THEIR NUMBER OF COUNTIES ARE IN
THE BAY AREA FIVE AT LEAST
COUNTY THAT ALREADY ALLOW FOR
THAT FOR AVAILABILITY AND THESE
ARE VERY WEALTHY HI A HOT HOUSE
SHOULDN'T PROPERTY VALUED
COMMUNITIES THAT- THAT ALREADY
HAVE THAT SO IT'S A- NOT MUCH
OF A LOSS THERE. WELL ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. MS BATES THE JOKER.
HI I'M DO WE HAVE A FILE ON
THIS WE HAVE A RESPONSE FROM%
INFORMATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE LA- OR FRANCHISED
APARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL. IT
SEEMS TO BE SOMETHING THAT'S
REALLY PROBLEMATIC ON ON A BILL
LIKE THIS. CASE ONE REGISTER
THAT- A COMPLAINT. THESE ARE
THE FOLKS LIKE SIGNIFICANT
PHYSICAL ISSUE FOR THE- STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE EQUATION. AND IT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL TO HAVE MORE
INFORMATION ON WHAT THAT MEANS
IN TERMS OF THE PROPERTIES
GOING FORWARD. WE SPEND A LOT
OF TIME NOT IN OUR CHAMBERS
HERE ABOUT AFFORDABILITY AND IF
YOU THINK ABOUT THE IF. IT
COULD BE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON THE AFFORDABILITY OF HOUSING
ON THE SECOND TRANSFER OF AN
INHERITED PIECE OF PROPERTY.
FOR A FOR A NEW BUYER. WHILE
WAITING YEAR INCREASING THE
PROPERTY TAX LIKE THAT FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE. MOVING INTO THE
HOMES- AND I'M I'M THINKING
ABOUT. OF THE IN MY PART OF THE
WORLD DOWN THERE- THE MEDIAN
PRICE FOR HOMES ALONG THE
CLOSER OVER A MILLION DOLLARS
ON OR TO. OUR LOOKING OUT
MEDIAN HOME PRICES AND- BUT
FATAL GONNA BEACH. AND YOU HAVE
A VARIETY THERE ARE THERE ARE
HUGE EVEN IF IT FOR A- THREE
BEDROOM HOUSE WITH WITH THE
BATHROOM. THE ONLY NO YARDS SO.
I JUST THINK THERE SHOULD BE
WAY MORE FISCAL ANALYSIS WE
HAVE A REAL HANDLE ON. WITH
THEIR DAY IF HE IS AN IMPACT TO
AFFORDABILITY. THOUGHT IN A
STATE THAT'S ALREADY VERY HIGH
ON PROPERTY TAX AND OTHER COST
OF LIVING IN THE ABILITY.
REALLY TO MOVE ABOUT
COMMUNITIES AND MOVE UP. OF
FROM A STARTER HOME OUT TO A
LARGER ONE TO ACCOMMODATE
FAMILY OR- YOU KNOW- RELATIVES
WHATEVER. SO THAT WOULD BE MY
CONCERN WITH THEM. THE MATCH
DEEP DIVE IN TERMS OF THE REAL.
IMPACT TO. FAMILY AND
AFFORDABILITY FOR RESIDENTS I
IN OUR. STATE ROBBIE I WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO. IT TODAY. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY UP MR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN RESTAURANT AT A JUST
THE LET YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
SOME THINGS IN HERE THAT I
REALLY DO SUPPORT OBVIOUSLY THE
TAX PORTABILITY. IS A GOOD IDEA
AND BEING ABLE TO- ALLOWING IN
THOSE TEN COUNTIES THAT
RECIPROCATE ITH THAT NOW-
REQUIRING ALL FIFTY COUNTIES TO
DO THAT I THINK IS A GOOD IDEA
IT WILL CREATE I BELIEVE.
MOVEMENT IN THE IN THE MARKET
THE HOUSING MARKET WILL I THINK
HELP. MORE HOUSES COME UP FOR
SALE THAT. THE LONG TERM
WOULDN'T. I'M I'M ALSO YOU KNOW
IS THIS MIGHT BE SHOCKING TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE THE- THESE. ROB
PARENT CHILD. EXCLUSION A AYE
AYE EVEN THOUGH I GET TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE THAT ONCE I NEVER
REALLY KIND UNDERSTOOD WHY THAT
WAS PART OF PROP THIRTEEN- INTO
SOME NOT COMPLETELY CLOSE
MINDED TO THAT IDEA THERE'S
JUST SOME OTHER THINGS IN THE
BILL THAT I IN IN ADDITION TO
WHAT- CENTER BATES SAID THEY
KIND OF GIVE ME SOME PAUSE ON
THIS PARTICULAR FULL PACKAGE
BUT I DID SHE DID ONE LET YOU
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME THINGS
IN THERE THAT I LIKE AND SOME
OTHER THINGS I'M OPEN MINDED TO
SOME. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
OTHER COMMENTS I WOULD MAKE ONE
COMMENT TO. WE ARE PLACING THIS
ON THE BALLOT AND SO THE VOTERS
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
BETWEEN NOW AND NOVEMBER- I'M
SURE THE- YOU KNOW INSTITUTIONS
AND ORGANIZATIONS AWAITING WITH
HER ANALYSIS. OF THE TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATIONS FROM THE REALTORS
TO. LEGAL WOMEN VOTERS YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WILL BE. ANALYZING THIS
SO WE HAVE AN INFORMED
ELECTORATE COME NOVEMBER TO
MAKE A DECISION AND SO. YOU
KNOW THAT GIVES ME COMFORT IN.
ALLOWING THIS TO MOVE OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY. IN THAT
IT'S NOT THE- THIS PARTICULAR
FEATURE. THE BILL BECOMES LAW
WE'RE PROVIDING THE
OPPORTUNITY. FOR THE RESIDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE THE FINAL
DECISION. WITH AMPLE TIME
BETWEEN NOW AND NOVEMBER. TWO
TO CREATE AN ANALYSIS OF THAT
SO. WITH THAT THE CHAIR WILL.
BE A SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE
AND DO WE HAVE A MOTION. OF
CLOSE YOU WANNA MAKE A CLOSE
THEY CAN ASSURE FOR THAT POINT
ABOUT THE VOTERS A MAKING THE
ULTIMATE DECISION HERE ON THIS
WE ARE IN A RELATIVELY TIGHT
TIMING WINDOW- GIVEN THE AYE
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE FOR THE
EXISTING MEASURE TO BE PULLED
OFF. I'M CONFIDENT- THOUGH THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE- WILL SUBMIT
THIS TO THE VOTERS- FOR THEIR
CONSIDERATION TO SUMMARIZE VERY
BRIEFLY ACA LEVIN LAD TO THE OF
AVAILABLE. AND ULTIMATELY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK ACA
LEVEL WILL HELP FUND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THROUGH GREATER TAX
FAIRNESS. AND VERY IMPORTANTLY
AS WE- LOOK AT FIRE SEASON THIS
FALL THAT WILL BETTER PROTECT
LIVES AND PROPERTY OF FROM
WILDFIRES AND FOR THOSE REASONS
AND MORE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. WE HAVE A MOTION. OF
LEYVA MOTION THING NUMBER FOR
THE COMMENTS AND A CLOSE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ACA ELEVEN THE
MOTION IS THAT THE MEASURE BE
ADOPTED REFER TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
I HAVE BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES. JONES NO LEYVA.
LEYVA I LIKE OWSKI HIGH CASKEY
BY ADDRESS FIVE BILLS HAS FIVE
VOTES SO IT IS OUT ON FIVE BOTH
FROM MAKE SURE THAT I COVER
EVERYTHING SO- THAT CONCLUDES
OUR HERE FOR THE DAY I'D LIKE
TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO SUBMIT YOUR TESTIMONY FOR
ANY REASON YOU STILL CAN ADD
YOUR COMMENTS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
WRITING- OR VISIT THROUGH THE
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE ALWAYS WELL
RECEIVED A PLEASE TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION I ALSO LIKE
TO THANK EVERYBODY WHO WAS HERE
IN THE COOPERATION OF OUR STAFF
AND THE COMMITTEE AND THAT
CONCLUDES. OUR MEETING TODAY WE
ARE ADJOURNED.